Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 1st April 1st or wait a minute,
isn't this when everybody fools everybody look at all these fucking wires all
jammed around together.
How the fuck does this happen every week?
Well bell cause you just,
you just throw it around.
You throw are you throw around your equipment,
it gets all fucking locked together.
I'm happy.
April fool's day,
everybody,
we're in a month for an old Billy.
No boobs is fucking cruising along.
Four months into this fucking thing.
Uh,
November 24th so I don't know,
that's 120 something.
27 days,
28 days of as of today,
which is the longest I think I've gone since that time.
I took a year off.
So my record is 367 days since I first started boozing around 17 years old.
So the first 17 years of my life,
I cruised other than you,
I snuck a beer here or there,
you know,
when I was in my teens because I didn't want my first beer that I ever had to be
in front of other fucking people.
I remember my dad had strose,
that's what he used to drink.
He had strokes.
I don't even know if they still make that shit.
He had it in the refrigerator and I would fucking,
you know,
sneak one,
not realizing you had no idea how fucked up on my going to get.
And I would,
I would only drink like a third of it.
And then I would,
uh,
I would pour the thing out,
the rest of it down the fucking sink.
That was my big foray into everything.
Everything I've ever done.
I always stuck my toe into it like,
Ooh,
ah,
what bad things gonna happen.
Um,
so,
which is probably better for you,
you know,
longterm.
But,
um,
I will tell you what the,
you know,
going to bed sober really makes you kind of force a face.
You're a,
you're fucking Damon's man.
I was really thinking like,
ah,
you know,
I drink to take the edge off little stress,
it's nice.
It's nice to just have one and just fucking relax,
which it is hoes kid.
No,
it's fucking delicious.
Ah,
oh my God,
I got it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I,
you know,
the amount of times I've gone,
it's starting to fade.
But you know,
these first few fucking months,
man,
it's been a couple of bars that I've seen and I just think like,
especially during the day,
I just think like what would happen if I just went in there right fucking now
marched right in there and got a beer and a shot.
It just did that for the next four hours,
came home.
Then I come home to my wife and kid at four 30 in the afternoon,
hammered and then what?
You know,
they would be looking at me like,
what,
what?
What do we mean fucking Angela's ashes,
kind of an asshole in 2019 with a wife and kid at home goes out and gets fucking
hammered at a,
but I'll tell you as much as I know not to do that,
the,
the thought is definitely there,
but,
uh,
yeah.
So as I've mentioned a thousand fucking times,
and I know you guys are getting sick of this,
but I just say to you,
say it to you,
so I'll do it.
I'm taking this year off.
I'm not talking to you guys right now.
I'm talking to me.
You understand me?
You're prepping.
Cut.
Yeah.
Well,
take a year off.
So,
um,
which I think I'll be able to do.
No problem.
The only fucking tough day that I see between me and let's see,
I would break my record.
I want a year and two days.
November 24th,
25th,
26th.
November 20 sec seventh is when I would break my record.
Right?
My own personal bests.
The willpower is I'm going to the,
I'm going to be going to the Clemson Florida state football game,
um,
in October and I'm going to be,
uh,
you know,
we already,
like we have the lodging,
we're going to be out there for a couple of days.
Uh,
I'm actually trying to get a gig at Clemson,
everybody,
which is probably career suicide now with everybody with their hashtags,
flipping the fuck out and all of that shit.
Um,
I would love to do a Gig at like sort of a pre football rally for the Florida
state game and uh,
I'm so fucking excited for that game,
but I'm going to be there with,
you know,
my best friends in the world and uh,
I know I'm going to smoke half a box of cigars.
Um,
I just got,
I just can't do the fucking,
oh my God.
Is that going to be hard
sitting on a fucking lake,
drinking fucking club sodas in Lima with Lyme?
Oh my God.
I mean,
you know,
certain times in this country you get fucking deported for that,
but whatever.
I'm going to do it.
I'll do it.
The one thing I do like about not boozing those,
it's really easy to keep the fucking,
the old pasty belly at a,
at a,
uh,
a decent fucking level.
Um,
although I've noticed I've started to eat a little bad lately just because just
coming home you want to catch some sort of a something.
I'm just so used to something at the end of the fucking day that I've literally,
I started drinking root beer.
Like I'm fucking like,
I still have a paper route was like,
I'm still nine years old.
Um,
so I got to watch that,
you know,
cause that's like hitting the crack pipe of fucking sugar.
You know,
it's a motherfucker man.
Like people who were like straight edge.
Like I,
I would love to sit down with somebody who's just totally straight edge and just
talk to them
about like,
can you imagine you didn't drink,
you didn't smoke.
And then on top of that you actually ate.
Like what?
What do they call that?
Diet?
The probiotic die,
whatever the fuck I was,
remember that those people actually read up on nutrition and they barely work
out and get fucking abs and shit.
You know those people.
Okay.
Who truly they treat,
they treat their body like a fucking classic car.
You know what I mean?
Like you know the ones that it's just like,
dude,
do you even drive that fucking thing?
Like every fucking nut and bolt has been chromed.
Um,
it's kind of,
I've just been thinking about that going like,
wow,
that's really what if I treated my body like that because I know I haven't,
I've treated my,
you know,
I,
I've treated my body in the last 15 years,
like a station wagon,
you know,
the family station wagon.
Okay.
The fake wood paneling on the side.
That's kind of how I've,
I've done it.
So,
I mean,
it's not like I've been,
you know,
back in the day when all eight went to high school in the 80s,
and I remember my buddies of mine where they go out and go buy like the used
fucking trans am that one from the late seventies with the fucking screaming
flaming chicken on the hood.
6.6 liter.
You don't say it on this side.
And they did think it was always just like Carl look cool.
It sounded cool,
but it,
it was driven the way it was meant to be driven for fucking eight years,
nine years and now you got it.
Um,
and those things would it yeah,
would always end up fucking shit in the bed.
My buddies would buy him in the fucking thing would die like three months later
would need some major God damn work.
Um,
so anyway,
um,
I've been just sort of a
trying to think like that.
Like try to go more in that direction.
Like,
all right,
what if I quit cigars are released,
reign it in,
or if I read a little more on nutrition,
you know,
what if I kept reading,
and I just send me,
what if I kept reading and every other word out of my mouth is,
you know,
I'm too fucking stupid.
Right?
Um,
I've gotten back and into like learning French
and uh,
I'm doing really well with it now.
I actually got a friend of mine that speaks French and this person will text me
only in French and I can actually translate a lot of it now kind of psyched and
a,
I'm just going to keep doing that.
I told you I went to that,
that that private school we were trying to find,
cause a fucking,
all the schools out here is public schools suck.
So now we've got to try to find a private school to go to.
Okay.
And we went to this one,
um,
that I really loved.
Still love it.
But the lady there,
you know,
they teach the kids how to speak French,
right?
Some real fucking aristocratic,
fucking a private school shit.
I said,
hey,
can the parents learn it with them?
And they're just like,
she's like,
no,
it's,
it's too late for you.
Yeah.
And I want to thank her for saying that because it really motivated me.
I just want like,
you know what?
All right,
well I'll show you fucking show you.
I'll come out of nowhere.
It's going on.
They're taught six simple.
Say it all in fucking French.
Um,
speaking of which I,
my,
the love of my life,
my beautiful daughter to her first movie this week,
I was so excited.
You know,
she's all about going to the park and all of that.
I bought a pitch back matter.
The pitch backs you used to have as a kid,
you know,
you could adjust them at three if we couldn't even adjustment three different
angles.
The one I had was like sort of concave shape.
So if you throw it out the top,
it would give your ground or you through at the bottom,
you get a pop up.
If you threw it straight in,
it'd be like you had a friend that you were playing catch with.
So,
um,
I bought a killer one of those and uh,
I was trying to show her how to use it and she didn't get it,
so she would just run up with the ball and she hit it off the net and then turn
around and then throw it at me.
And uh,
I kind of was kind of getting her to figure out how to do that stuff.
And um,
okay.
You know,
I know it's still,
it's the toys beyond it because it's going to come back and hit and hit her.
That's what I'm worried about.
But,
uh,
I got to run the right path.
I already get my,
my uh,
one of my relatives got assist these little hockey nets and she actually goes
watch hockey.
And then like why we're watching hockey,
he like,
she's running around with the stick and the ball,
you know,
I'm fucking with my old niece is on the floor trying to play goal and shit.
So it's,
it's,
it's all coming together.
It's all coming together.
I just needed to get her a little bit taller and then I'm going to start
teaching her how to drive my fucking truck.
Um,
but anyways,
so I was driving around La and I saw these billboards that said Dumbo March 29th
and I'm like,
oh my God,
they,
we,
I'm going to take my kid to a movie.
She's big enough now.
We're going to go there,
we'll get some popcorn and candy,
some fucking drinks.
The whole thing is going to be great.
So we went over there,
you know,
my wife was going to come with me and then at the last second she,
she got something she had to go do and she goes,
you just go,
you go,
this would be good,
you know,
bonding time,
daughter with a dead.
So we go there.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
and first of all,
I couldn't find the fucking movie,
which theater we were supposed to go in.
They were all numbered,
you know,
when you can't find your gate at the airport.
And I fucked that whole thing up somehow.
And like,
where the fuck is this?
He know.
And I went to therapy about my anger.
So I'm really trying to keep it cool
and I'm just like,
who came up with a numbering system here that I can't find,
you know,
theater number nine or whatever.
Right?
So it turns out,
because it was like the Imax Dolby surround sound fucking,
and I was just like,
wow,
they're going all out.
So you know,
it's hilarious.
I'm sitting there carrying all her stuff,
carrying the popcorn and leaving this trail of popcorn and stuff.
But I'm loving every second and we get in there and we have like these
individual seats that like recline.
So I sat her in the seat next to me.
This is all dude sit next to me.
A couple of other people in our row.
We went to like the 10 30 in the morning showing right?
And I sit her down and I put the big box up,
a bag of popcorn.
Right.
You know,
she's sitting there,
you know,
a little cute little legs,
right?
Put a right between the legs,
just,
just sitting there and she's just eating it and she's just looking over at me
like,
I don't know what this is,
but I,
I'm in,
I love this.
Right.
I'm keeping away from the candy though,
you know,
the sugar or whatever.
Right.
So just the salt,
right.
I mean,
what am I gonna do?
Um,
I have this weird thing where I'm feeding her healthy food,
but like,
also I think a kid should have McDonald's.
Like,
I'm not going to take it to that fucking level,
you know,
gluten free fucking pizza.
I mean,
at some point,
you know,
I don't know,
it's probably a bad thing,
but,
um,
whatever everybody raises their kid the way they want to.
And like,
I think you've got to have a balance of like a little more progressive shit with
also,
you know,
they fall down,
you say rub some dirt on it.
You know what I mean?
You don't want an animal,
but you don't want to pussy either.
You got to have that fucking,
that you gotta have,
you gotta raise somebody that's going to be able to go out in the world and be
able to stick up for themselves.
And I think that starts at Mcdonald's.
No,
anyway,
so we're sitting there and the coming attractions are happening,
you know,
and everything's fine or whatever.
And she's just eating the popcorn.
Like she's just like,
like fish to water.
Like,
Oh,
I get this,
I watched this and I eat this popcorn.
I sit in this great chair,
this is,
she's not even looking at me.
Right.
Um,
and then the movie starts
and it didn't even dawn,
I thought it was a cartoon.
I thought it was an animated thing.
Right.
I didn't fucking realize that it was live action.
And Tim Burton made it.
This was not a kids movie and it was like Pg or whatever,
which is,
you know,
PG is a joke,
but when you got like a two year old,
you know,
it's fucking guys like yelling at the elephants and being all mean,
Hollywood's whole,
you know,
zoos are bad circuses or bad kind of theme.
You know,
and,
uh,
we got about fucking three minutes into it and she looked over at me and she put
her arms up,
which means,
you know,
pick me up.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
And it was loud.
Okay.
So I picked her up.
Um,
no,
she had talked a little bit and the guy next to me kind of looked over me like,
what the fuck?
And I'm thinking like,
really,
dude,
we're in Dumbo.
I got a little kid,
he to kids talking and then all of a sudden it puts together,
oh,
he's looking at me like,
what the fuck did you bring a kid to a Tim Burton movie for?
So now I put in my arms with their head buried into my neck,
which she does when she's shy,
when there's too many people around or she's uncomfortable.
And so now I'm sitting there trying to be like,
oh hey honey,
look at the elephants,
the elephants.
And she's just sort of looking back at the screen.
And then,
you know,
going back and then after,
like,
I swear to God,
we made maybe 15 minutes and I just whispered in her ear and I just go,
uh,
you want to go home to mommy?
And she just goes,
yeah.
It's like,
all right,
we're out of here.
So I only saw the first 15,
20 minutes of it.
Uh,
all I can tell you is Danny Devito as always crushing it.
I was loving him.
Colin Farrell was in it.
I mean,
I was in,
I was enjoying,
it's Tim Burton,
just having a good time.
You know,
it's funny when before I went over there,
you know,
somebody was trying to say and all that I think didn't do too well on,
on fucking rotten tomatoes.
And I'm like,
well,
what the fuck?
Kind of fucking,
what do they get?
Five-Year-Old's going on rotten tomatoes,
be like,
Eh,
kind of a rip off of Pinocchio.
And once I got there and I look,
you know,
I dunno,
I,
I think when I got home was when somebody told me it was a Tim Burton movie.
But as I was walking out,
I,
and I just was,
the whole thing felt bad.
Like there was a fucking,
there was a fight and this guy was punching this guy in the face.
I was like,
oh,
this is fucking like,
what?
Just just shit I've always watched,
but now I've got a kid.
Then I'm like,
what the fuck?
This is kind of a,
it's kind of that going get going pretty hard here for a kid's movie.
I'm such an idiot.
It wasn't until I left and I looked around and I realized that I was the all
like everybody there was like my age almost,
well now my age,
I'm fucking,
well the guy next to me,
it was like,
he had like 10 years on me,
but,
um,
it was all adults.
So a big swing and a miss for me.
And uh,
we still at a good time.
She loved the popcorn,
you know?
Um,
she still says that she's walking around go movie movie,
popcorn,
popcorn or yup,
yup.
I go loud.
Right.
She goes loud,
loud.
So anyways,
uh,
I did at least get to experience that,
which is,
um,
which is pretty amazing considering,
you know,
this is my first kid,
um,
I've ever had,
so I've never gotten to,
you know,
okay.
I've never had a kid at this age before,
so I never got to go take him to do something like that.
Um,
which opened up this whole world of like,
Oh my God,
I'm going to get you.
Maybe she gets into sports.
I get to go to her games,
I get to take it a games driver,
friends to the games and go to movies and find out what the hell she's into and,
you know,
hang out before they become a teenager,
at which point they need their space,
which I,
I get,
you know.
Okay.
It kinda gave me like it like,
oh,
this is a whole new chapter of this part of this ride that's going to be really
cool because she's already stopped doing some stuff that I loved,
you know,
but then they,
they learn how to talk better,
you know what I mean?
As opposed to me.
But,
uh,
yeah,
she used to say no when you'd be like,
hey sweetie,
do you want a,
you want some more cereal?
And she put her hand out and kind of look,
put her eyebrows down.
Look the floor.
I'd be like,
yeah,
no,
no.
Yo
me.
And they used to laugh and just sort of joke like lowly only need to say at once
and every time we'd always,
yeah,
Yo Yo yo Yo,
Yo
felt like I was like trying to hang a picture on the wall and she was like some
super rich person across the room.
Like that's not it.
No,
no,
totally wrong.
So she doesn't do that anymore,
but she does a other stuff,
you know.
Um,
I've gotten to do like more like interactive,
you know,
and they're just like a baby just carrying them around like this.
It's like you have the hope diamond,
you're like terrified.
Now she runs around,
she falls down,
she's fine.
I've gone swimming and shit with her and all of that stuff.
So it's,
it's really cool watching her become like a little person.
So,
um,
anyways,
any way you guys are telling me,
uh,
F one,
the second race of the year in Bahrain.
I watched that today and you know,
I'm rooting for Ferrari just because,
you know,
whenever I take on a new sport,
I can't root for the Patriots team or the,
the,
uh,
the Golden State Warriors,
whoever the dominant team is,
you can't just like pile on and be like,
oh,
I liked the best team.
So Ferrari obviously they're no slouches but they've just been,
they've been in a Rut since I've been watching.
I think this is my third or fourth season watching and um,
it's,
let's see.
Well,
Louis wanted the,
Nico Rosberg won it and then Louis one,
it's,
this is my fourth season watching,
I believe,
or Lewis won the last two years and Nico was Nico One the first year I watched.
But I think I'm in my fourth season of watching this stuff and I have to be,
I've got to tell you this right now.
I swear to God,
watch rooting for the Ferrari team is feeling like it's,
it's like rooting for the Kansas City chiefs or the Toronto Maple leafs.
The fucking,
who else?
San Jose Sharks.
The San Diego chargers,
those fucking teams,
that dad,
they're right there.
They're right there and then,
fuck you
G.
I'm watching this fucking race.
And you know,
Lewis Hamilton did not have a good race the first time.
And you know that guy.
I really like him.
I like what he does,
but he,
you know,
he acts like a fucking baby though when he's not winning.
And he's always at,
Oh,
what's,
what's Botox too?
And how come he's not helping me out?
It's like,
well,
when you're leading the race,
you're not thinking about helping him out.
You know,
I never been able to like think like,
is that like how you have to be to be as good as him?
You gotta be that selfish.
It's just really off putting as a fan to be watching that.
So I'm watching the race.
The Ferrari's have won the poll and second place and then the Mercedes,
or in third and fourth.
All right.
I think this Charles look clerk,
is that how you say his name?
He was on pole.
Um,
Vettel had a better start and uh,
I think Leclerc if somebody was having a problem with their grip around the
first three turn turns,
didn't warm up their tires enough and a botox was breathing down in breathing
down his fucking neck,
you know,
and uh,
but then one would say straightened out after a couple of fucking lapse,
the Ferrari's for like in control.
It was a really interesting race.
So then Louis went in early and he got some soft tires and all of a sudden he
started fucking catching up,
which made vental have to fucking,
but like the Ferrari's,
we're just stronger.
They would just better cars and just,
we're better today.
And then they did think this,
they fuck the whole fucking thing up.
Okay.
You know,
it's also punching up a fucking episode of a F is for family is I'm always
fucking multitasking.
I don't know what happened to Vela battles front wing,
but he fucking spins out.
But Charles law clerk and he has like a fucking,
he had like a 25 second lead on Lewis Hamilton and he's this like 12 laps to go.
The fucking race is over.
And I'm like,
this is great.
Okay,
Hamilton's going to go all for two as far as winning races.
And you know,
he's calming,
you know he's going to win is racist.
Maybe there'll be nice and close for the rest of the fucking year
and no 12 labs to go.
All of a sudden Charlo shot rob my car on the fucking turbo,
shits the bed
and then you just gotta Watch fucking Hamilton run them down and then fucking
botox passes Oma.
Now the Mercedes or in first and second they have fucking for it and they just
fucking screwed the pooch.
And then at least,
you know,
Renault was in,
was nice enough to have both their cars,
shit the bed.
So then they,
they finished under a caution flag.
So,
um,
look,
clerk was,
I think,
did he,
I think he might've stayed on the podium and Vernon Vettel was kind of in fifth
place.
What do we got here?
Let me see what,
let me see the,
uh,
the positions here.
I looked it up here,
fon standings I have,
and that's not what I want.
It was Lewis Hamilton,
Botox,
law clerk,
and then uh,
oh max for staffing and then Vettel so he came in fifth place.
Okay.
And then here are the standings for the year.
Botox has 44 points points for Mercedes.
And then Hamilton has 43.
Yeah,
Max Verstappen is a 27.
And then the Ferrari team there are 26 and 22
like that now I now,
so now you know what it is now.
Like all I'm going to do is route for botox because I did like the racing
between the two teammates,
botox and Hamilton.
Like fuck you dude.
Like I botox has done being the fucking,
you know,
the bridesmaid or the Goddamn gimp of that team.
And that could be really fun because that first year with Nico Rosberg and uh,
I hope I'm saying his name right and Lewis Hamilton.
That was,
it's like watching days of thunder the way they didn't get along.
So,
um,
let me get a drink of water here.
Hang on.
Okay.
But anyways,
when uh,
you know,
it was fucking hilarious when,
um,
when the Hamilton passed a law clerk,
I literally gave the finger to the TV,
both fingers and I'm just like,
why?
Why am I mad at Lewis Hamilton?
What?
Cause he's good.
You know what he reminds me of?
He's like death.
Remember that smart kid at school had the great penmanship and always fucking,
you know,
did everything that you knew you should've been doing but you weren't,
it's like,
why?
Why am I going to hate the guy because he's fucking good.
Just drives me fucking nuts.
It's like,
it just,
it takes me back to being a Boston sports fan before we started winning.
And it was just,
they was just like,
how many fucking times can these cons get the call?
How many times can just the ball just fucking bouncing to this guy's hand?
Like just getting the breaks.
Like Mercedes got really fucking lucky today,
or what?
I think they just a better team.
I don't know what the fucking deal is with Ferrari.
They make some of the greatest cars in history that just,
I don't know.
It was frustrating.
I was really hoping,
you know,
the first five get five,
six races in and,
and Ferrari had like a nice decent lead.
And then to watch Mercedes play catch up for once.
It's just,
you know,
it's just not,
it's not their time.
So we shall see.
We shall see what happens.
Um,
anyways,
let me see what we got here.
Andrew was asking me if I wanted to answer any more of these fucking,
uh,
tax questions,
which I'll,
I,
you know,
I'll do it.
I'll answer another one.
I don't know.
Um,
I just have no fucking idea.
How are you going to convince me that you should basically punish honest
Americans who happen to be making over $10 million a year?
Um,
and the fact that she would co sign on that
as a fellow American to punish those fucking people and make them pay for all
these people who don't pay any mind any taxes.
All these corporations that don't pay any taxes,
all these corporations that fucking drag us into these never ending fucking
wars.
Never ending fucking wars and make a fucking fortune.
Okay,
author the death and destruction,
and that's all a separate issue.
It's all a fucking separate issue.
And you know what?
You know what?
We can fucking tax these people because they actually report their fucking
income.
So God damn it,
I'm not making 10 million a year,
so fuck them.
Well,
I'm not making 10 million a year either,
and I don't say fuck them.
I don't leave him the fuck alone.
Um,
and go after the fucking problem.
All right?
Don't paint a house that has a broken foundation or that needs a new foundation,
I should say.
All right,
well by the way,
I'm going to be in New York City Tuesday,
flying in Tuesday morning,
getting off the plane,
going right over to Msg,
uh,
for the garden of dreams.
And you know what they're saying?
Dreams.
Okay?
At eight fucking the main room with a Nixon,
the fucking rangers play cause that,
that's the garden of nightmares.
I'm talking about the theater at Madison Square Garden where Eddie Murphy
recorded raw,
legendary place,
the garden of dreams that I'm on this show.
Unbelievable.
Show that has,
let me,
let me read the lineup here because Brian Regan was tweeting about it.
Uh,
I,
I had no idea.
Listen to listen to this fucked garden of dreams.
April,
saccades.
Come on bill.
Type faster.
Here we go.
Okay.
Though at the Hulu Theater,
all star lineup announced.
All right,
listen to this.
We're waiting bill.
It is
Jesus fucking Christ.
Tiffany Haddish.
Yeah.
Michael Che,
Brian Regan.
Jerry Seinfeld,
Jon Stewart,
Jon Stewart.
Uh,
John Malaney.
Yeah,
I thought Eliza Schlesinger was on it.
I Dunno.
And Yours truly.
Oh,
and also Steve [inaudible] is going to be hosting it.
Um,
typical me,
I don't even know what the fuck this is for.
And you will all start benefit that is raised nearly $5 million so far.
For what?
Okay.
Is a foundations nonprofit with 30 partnering organizations throughout the Tri
State area,
including hospitals,
wish organizations and Q.
Okay.
All gardener dreams make a wish.
It's like a make a wish thing.
Okay,
cool.
So I'll be doing that.
Or Billy new jokes coming to town.
Did I fucking eat my fucking freckle dick the other night?
Jesus Christ.
I took a nice fat one at the fucking belly rump.
Went up there with some new jokes.
Oh my God.
Terrible fucking terrible.
I had this great fucking thing on people who are watching that Michael Jackson
fucking documentary.
It absolutely fucking destroyed,
destroyed.
And then the very next night,
two nights later I go to do it and I never take myself cause I just,
I I,
you know,
cause I know I'm not going to listen to it.
I wish I take that night cause I went and tried to do the same thing and all I
got was groans.
So that might just be one of those things where,
you know,
one night it worked and it just never worked again.
Then I just sit there,
you know,
like somebody who had loved and then lost it.
MMM.
Speaking of having love of that and lost it,
let's read a little bit of the advertising here.
Um,
the fuck did I do with it?
MMP content.
All right,
here we go.
Live raids the raids that are alive.
Oh wait,
did I,
did I attach them?
Oh I did.
Oh look who it is.
Hi,
you have a buy something online only to find out later.
You missed a discount.
I don't know.
Did I had a fuck what?
I find that out.
What a mean Old Lady of their coupons on the Internet.
I had no idea.
I didn't know about this shit.
Anyways.
Uh,
don't overspend anymore.
Go to honey.
Oh honey is a free browser.
Add ons that finds you the best deals online.
The APP magically auto applies the best deal to your cart and checkout.
Honey finds discounts and coupons across 37,000 sites.
Isn't that amazing?
Amazon Safora,
bestbuy Norstrom and more honey is saved.
It's $10 million.
10 million members,
an average of $28 and 61 cents
wait per purchase.
Okay,
well,
it depends on what you buy.
That's a little vague.
Hi.
Hey,
members have already saved more than $800 million.
Jesus Christ.
Not Bad for some.
I guess that means per purchase,
10 million turns into 800 billion.
Not Bad for something that's completely free and takes just two clicks to
install.
This thing is free.
Well,
you know,
they probably track something.
I mean,
nothing's free in this world.
Is it?
Is it honey?
Hey,
honey has over a hundred thousand five star reviews on Google Chrome Store Time
magazine calls,
honey.
Basically free money.
Look,
there's really no reason not to use.
Hi honey.
Oh honey.
Yeah.
It's free to use and easy to install on your computer and just two clicks.
So shop with confidence.
Get honey for free@joinhoney.com slash bird that's joined honey.com/burr hi
smart shopping assistant.
That saves you time and money when you're shopping online.
Oh look who's next?
Oh,
I only have two reeds.
I love it.
Policy genius.
Hey,
can you fog and believe it's April already?
MMM.
Do you know it says that people who don't live in towns that have fucking the
winner or part of the world,
you know what I mean?
I remember Massachusetts January,
February,
and the horrific hope of March.
Okay.
In like a lamb.
I'll like a lot.
You know,
it just socked 31 fucking days of it.
Okay.
Before I had to fucking pay,
you know,
rent and everything.
February always fucking dragged.
Even though it was only 28 days,
it was still the middle of fucking,
oh wait,
you got your February vacation though.
That was kind of cool when I was in school anyways.
Can you believe it's already April time has a habit of getting away,
but if you have a mortgage kids already,
what?
Depending on your income,
you're going to have to spend some of that precious time to get life insurance.
If you need life insurance but you don't want to spend a lot of time comparing
it,
you should give policy genius a try.
Policy Genius is the easy way to buy life insurance online.
It's just two minutes.
You can compare in just two minutes.
You can compare quotes from the top insurers and find out the best price.
Once you apply the policy genius team will handle all of the paperwork and the
red tape,
no commissions,
no hidden fees,
just more time saved for you.
So if you need life insurance but you're not,
but you're short on time,
had to policy genius.com and compare quotes.
Policy Genius is easy.
It saves you money.
And not to Belabor the point,
but it's fast.
What policy?
Genes is easy.
It saves you money.
And not to Belabor the point,
it's,
it should just say it's fast,
not,
but it's,
it's fast.
I Dunno.
Policy gene and spend less time comparing life insurance and more time doing
literally anything else.
All right,
let's get back to the podcast here.
Um,
all right.
Moto GP had their second race of the year.
I know Mark Marquez has,
I didn't get a chance to watch it yet.
Um,
I'm going to try to do that.
I'm going to finish this podcast and hang out with my little beautiful kid here
and uh,
and then I might check that out tonight cause I ain't doing shit.
I'm not doing shit tonight.
Hanging out with the wife,
going to get a little quality time in there.
Um,
I did a benefit Saturday night at the palace theater here in downtown La.
I got to play drums.
Um,
the portion of the show that I was on was a,
it's an ms benefit rock against ms and um,
just a great event.
I've done it twice.
Ansi B sale puts the thing together and it's always this great mix of incredible
musicians that I grew up watching.
And I,
you know,
when I get to sit in with all these fucking great people and I,
I played highway to hell,
which I think I played live at this time,
like a half a dozen times.
But this is the first time I played it where I,
I felt like I had the least amount of,
uh,
fuck ups.
You know,
it's funny,
in the middle,
that's such an easy song to fuck up a,
at least at my level,
because you know,
in the middle where he's going down,
stop man,
bad at a bed and a bad,
you know,
it's sort of,
it's like a three against four thing.
So you're supposed to of one and two and three and four,
one,
two,
three,
four,
one and two and three and four and one and two and three,
four really simple.
But in my head,
whenever I'm playing the song,
because I played that song a million fucking times and never thought about it,
I could just feel it.
But all of a sudden I'm playing it.
I'm not playing along to the track and I got fucking people.
I grew up watching on MTV.
It's turning around looking at me.
I get,
fuck,
it fucks me up.
Right?
So that one is basically a,
I always hear it is one and a two into three and that was just like,
oh no,
where am I?
And I was playing along the ACDC and I just started thinking about it and all of
a sudden I was fucking it up playing along the highway.
I played along in that song if 30 for 30 fucking years,
never thought about it.
All right.
The day of the Gig,
I'm playing along to it and I'm thinking about this part going,
I at least I got to know how to count this out,
figure out what this is.
After all these years of playing it.
And I started fucking it up.
So I'm backstage just going,
I'm going one and two and three and four
one and two and three and four and one and two and three for like I'm going to
do that.
So,
of course when the time comes,
so the song fucking comes,
you know,
we start playing the fucking song.
We get to that point.
Uh,
Michael Devin from Whitesnake is singing and um,
okay.
I immediately,
I still,
you know,
Pata Pata at that bar and I had no idea.
So I just fucking went real hard with the high hat.
So my,
my one would be there one what?
Well,
and then,
you know,
ended up getting out of it.
And,
um,
I had a great fucking time.
I don't like drum sounded awesome and I got to,
uh,
watch all these guys,
Stephen Parkins who was just on my podcast.
I got to watch him play my favorite van Halen Song of all time,
mean streets.
And uh,
what does it mean street?
This is home,
this is main street.
It's main street,
the movies mean streets.
I got to watch him play that.
And um,
just an incredible fucking drummer man.
You know,
some people look like their work and when they're playing,
that guy looks up there like he's just having the time of his fucking life and I
got to go on like right after him.
And um,
he's just,
he's the best fucking dude ever.
Uh,
so I'm hoping he's actually going to be
playing out live here where I can watch them do a full set.
That's what the fuck I would really like.
Um,
some,
oh,
what am I talking about?
He promoted that thing in the beginning of April.
Am I going to be around for that?
I think I am.
Hopefully I am.
MMM.
That thing in downtown La.
Now I'm literally just talking to myself.
I'm not even doing a fucking podcast anymore.
All right,
let's get to some of the questions here for the week.
I know the red sox have won one and lost two.
Um,
I love when they said the red sox have given up 18 runs of their past two games.
And I was like,
Jesus Christ,
we're getting lit up.
And then I see we only let up six the other night.
It's like,
all right,
so we let him 12 one night.
That fucking happens.
Um,
all right,
let's get to,
uh,
let's get to some of the questions here for the week.
See what I got here.
Um,
I'm hoping I'm not going to get trashed too much for my fucking,
my views here on taxes aren't athletes getting paid.
Hey bill receipt on your podcast.
You talked a little bit about why college athletes athletes should get paid.
Yeah.
But I also think that it should be like a flat fee,
so you don't have to bring in agents or anything like that.
They do a straight across the fucking board socialism thing here.
Um,
so you don't have high school holdouts and all of that or maybe that is the
wrong thing.
I have no idea.
Um,
I was just saying starters,
get this amount of money and if you have a Jersey that sells a lot,
you get a percentage of it and then everybody else who isn't a starter gets a
certain amount of fucking money.
Um,
and then that's it.
Straight across the fucking board.
Big Bang.
Boom.
Done.
All right.
Hey Bill.
Okay.
And I wanted to chime in on why it's harder than it seems not just because of
the greedy corporate comps.
Oh No,
it's,
it's fucking,
it'd be a fucking nightmare.
That's why I'm proposing a one sort of,
you know,
I get,
I dunno,
it's just fucked up that somebody is like,
okay,
selling a zillion jerseys with their name on the back.
Just coming from shell business.
I just know if I sold out a football fucking stadium,
um,
okay.
That I would get paid for it.
I would never do that show for free unless,
I guess it was a benefit.
But I can't see a football stadium worth of people.
This is weird thing where it's like you're coming in as a,
as a,
as a blue chip draft pick out of a recruit,
I should say out of high school.
And then
you're going to Michigan or USC or Alabama,
like these places they're going to sell out anyways because of the history.
So it's almost like you're joining a supergroup.
Right.
But it's kind of like the original members leave and now you have to carry on
the name.
So at first they're doing you a favor,
but once you establish yourself as a star,
then you're the one that's continuing.
You're the,
you're the draw that people are going to at that point,
they know your fucking name and that's,
that's gotta be some sort of money that would think,
you know,
anyways.
Um,
I'll also try to use simple language because I know you can't read out loud
worth of shit and neither can I.
Well,
I like the fact that your self draft McCree deprecating too,
right?
Paying athletes is all about who gets the larger and smaller pieces of the Pie.
Do football players get more than basketball players and soccer players?
Do Physical sports or activities get more than mentally exhausting sports or
activities and what counts as a sport or an athlete?
Okay.
Uh,
should the chess club or racketball players also get their share of money now?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I'm talking fucking,
you're f you're already famous.
You such a big time fucking college player.
You're already famous.
That's what I mean.
Okay.
Listen,
listen.
All right.
I would limit it to the sports at the school that have actually built the dorms.
You know what I mean?
Built the new fucking swimming pool for the fucking swim team.
I mean,
give me a fucking break here.
All right.
The amount of money that college football and college basketball brings in.
That's what the fuck I'm talking about.
All right.
And then lesser than that is a handful of hockey programs at least here in
America and uh,
in baseball.
But they don't bring in the money,
the TV march madness,
the bowl games,
the fucking playoffs system.
They now have football.
I mean,
that's a whole other fucking level.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
okay.
Basically the universities are pieces of shit because they take the federal
student aid money and then take a broadcasting and they then take broadcasting
companies money and pay fucking nobody in return.
It's smart,
but it's also a total dick move.
Okay.
We're all in this one.
We're on the same page here.
My thoughts are that schools who are getting money from any source of an event
like the Ncaa Tournament,
College Football playoff,
or the president's Cup chess championships,
well,
how much fucking money is that should be contributing to the players in some
way?
Medical travel shoes,
chessboards and so on.
Uh,
Musky.
You sound like a chess player to me,
man.
You bring it up chess way too much and is a for the slices of Pie,
the amount kickback to the athletes should be proportional.
Sorry,
had to use one big word.
Jesus.
Guys,
am I this bad fucking talking to me like I have brain damage.
Okay.
K Two,
the amount of the universe to the amount,
the,
uh,
the university.
Then I stumbled over the next five words.
All right.
Point taken.
You guys are right.
The university receives some of the event.
It's fucked up.
Yeah,
it's fucked up.
How to solve the paying athletes problem,
but something is better than nothing.
Anyways,
I'm a longtime listener.
Saw you in Portland,
Oregon last summer.
Keep being great and stay safe on your upcoming travels.
Sincerely,
nobody,
no name left to go fuck yourself.
Um,
yeah,
they should probably do.
So I would think that they,
it doesn't make any the amount of money that they're generating.
And then I love that argument.
Did getting a free education,
it's like,
okay.
You know,
it's like they,
they're going there to play football and try to make it into the NFL and their
body and their brain is never going to be the same.
They're going to do damage to their body that they're going to feel for the rest
of their fucking life.
Okay.
They don't have time to fucking go to class and do all of that shit.
Especially during the football season.
Yeah.
Can you imagine getting ready to play for Alabama and making sure you're turning
your paper in and at the same time they get a free education.
Now they get an education on,
on a,
okay.
I feel like the music businesses almost,
it's,
it's that much of a fuck over.
Even the music business.
Jesus Christ,
they back in the day,
they let you keep your fucking tore money and your t shirt,
you merge money.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
I dunno.
All right.
The number 70.
Yeah.
Hey,
bill,
simply put,
I think the interesting thing about the 70% tax rate argument is that most of
the people arguing for it don't even know why 70.
Okay.
Uh,
I would be one of those,
the green deal doesn't really just justify 70 or make it any more important than
say 65.
The team behind AOC,
I even know what that is,
gave her that number.
Her team is essentially socialists.
They're trying to make a capitalist argument in support of a socialist idea and
socialism,
there is no end game and like fascism,
it's a small group of people making decisions for everyone.
That's the capitalism is that way too.
We really got to stop like acting like capitalism,
you know,
Eh,
anybody can just ball up sells up by the bootstraps,
live like there's things aren't like locked down.
You know,
if that was true,
we would not have the gas combustion engine for as long as we have.
If that was true,
we would deal with global warming head on.
Um,
yeah.
Oh,
all forms of government.
Okay.
Socialism,
fascism,
capitalism,
whatever the fuck you want to call them.
They're all inherently flawed because they're run by human beings.
Okay.
Who are inherently flood yours truly one of the great cases of all time anyways.
Unless we wipe out all the congress and replaced the millionaires with average
joes who care about the earth and people and being fair,
they'll just use that power to spend all our money on selfless,
selfish causes.
It's human nature.
It absolutely is.
And that's a,
that's another part of my argument.
It's like,
okay,
so these are the tax dollars that are,
they're actually gonna use,
you know,
so public schools are better.
I get healthcare,
fix the roads,
help out the people in Flint,
Michigan,
you know,
help out veterans.
This,
these are the tack store dollars are actually going to get to them and they're
not.
They're not.
It is a broken system.
I'm just hoping the fine folks at Blackwater,
um,
you know,
they have the weaponry to,
to,
to have a full on fucking revolution.
Hopefully the,
their hearts are in the right place.
Who knows?
We shall see.
Um,
friend is a flat earth.
Okay.
What,
I don't understand how this,
this made a comeback.
I really feel like this is just people trolling.
I just can't imagine that this is,
this is an actual thing.
I mean,
God knows I'm not a fucking smart guy.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What people are going to sit here and act as though this is actually a thing.
Um,
how did this start?
Friend is a flat earthers hey Billy global tits
that,
you know,
that's the best one in a while.
I'm a 28 year old living in New York.
One of my best friends is a flat earthers.
Not only him but his girlfriend as well.
Well,
you know,
they fucked missionary style,
Huh?
What do they call it?
Earth style.
Uh,
I know I've known them for over five years.
So recently I sent him a cool video of two space.
Okay.
Is that acts or 10 rockets?
Vertically landing.
I would expect his normal reaction like,
oh,
that's so cool.
It's amazing what people can do nowadays.
But instead of that,
he started talking about how we've been lied to the whole time that all the
space program,
Isis and all of that is a global hoax.
Oh Man.
He went way down the rabbit hole.
Okay.
I started down that road and I headed back,
so I thought he was joking and I asked him,
are you a flat earner?
Arthur?
And he responded,
do research,
Bro.
Okay,
wait a second.
You know something?
I want to take this guy's advice
and I'm,
I'm going to do a little research here.
Flat Earth,
okay.
Evidence,
okay?
I can't imagine what the advertising I'm going to get.
Now.
Science,
Samia,
Hazmat suit and a fucking shelter.
Frequent hand flat or frequently asked questions.
What evidence do you have?
10 easiest way you can tell for yourself.
The earth is not flat,
okay?
This is evidence.
What if this is what proves the evidence?
Like all these smarmy people taking all this time,
like can you imagine like if you know the world's fucking round,
right?
You been in a plane,
you'll looked at it,
you've seen it a flat,
or maybe they're just fucking near sighted people.
They can't see the roundness of the earth when they get up at 37,000 feet a flat
earth.
The flat earth model is an architect concept,
okay?
The flat earth explained.
Okay.
And the weirdest part isn't just that he believes the earth is flat.
I can't find anybody that says seven ways approved.
The earth is round.
You know what,
cause I'm on page one.
Why the earth is actually a hundred percent flat.
Okay,
hang on a second.
Is this the one,
um,
you know,
I got to hit pause because I want to read these six hold on us.
Okay,
I'm back.
Right?
I just found a guy goes,
you know,
La Foil,
you guys say I'm a moron.
I uh,
did a,
uh,
I was on the math team and I a want a jury trial,
which are very difficult to win.
And uh,
I used to think that the world is round until I met my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ 40 years ago.
And it's like,
okay.
All right.
All right,
I'm out.
Tap it out,
tad.
God bless you.
God bless all the flat earthers.
Okay,
so what do they think?
They think the earth is round but of slap at the moon is round.
Okay.
How does the water not run off the eds?
I mean,
I've flown around the world.
I've done it.
I did a Gig,
I flew from La to Australia,
then I did Australia to fucking New Zealand.
And then I went to Singapore that I went to China,
that I went to India.
Then I went to New York,
I connected in Dubai.
We kept flying that fucking other way.
Granted,
I didn't have a compass.
He could have done a big slow fucking all the pilots in on it.
Uh,
you know who the,
I don't know where the fuck I'm going to,
you know,
that'd be,
that'd be really easy to fake you,
fake you in a plane,
you know,
just for a few times when I tried to do a little bit of instrument training in
the helicopter and they have you close your eyes and they just start doing shit
and you can just,
you have no fucking idea what's going on.
And I got to,
you know,
if you sit in the back of a plane,
you just looking out the side of it,
you,
you don't know what's going on.
Hey Man,
you know what?
Maybe it is flat,
man.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I just go,
Jesus Christ,
this guy found Jesus in the result of it was he thinks the fucking world is
flat.
Okay.
Anyways,
I've known them for over five years.
Let's just get back to this fucking thing.
Okay.
Uh,
so he said,
do your research bro.
The same day I called him and his girlfriend over to over to my house.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
I just looked at a guy who said he was a mathlete and he believes the world is
flat.
You believe it's round and you just wrote a fragment.
So right now the flat earthers are winning.
The same day I called him and his girlfriend over to my house,
period.
Anyways,
I'm going to tell you,
oh,
freckles.
I had much fun arguing with them,
but his response was,
I knew you were going to make fun of us,
not take us seriously.
Um,
I didn't,
I didn't mean to tell you,
it just slipped out of my mouth.
Next time I'll be cautious.
Now.
This is very unusual behavior for him.
He never had been so sensitive and cautious on any level.
He's biggest argument is that it's written in the Qur'an,
the Bible,
and the Torah,
that the earth is flat.
God laid the earth beneath our feet like a carpet for us to walk on.
Okay,
well he could still do that and it could be round
seal gravity thing.
Right?
I respect religion,
but like,
but like a comedy,
I can not take it literally.
It's all written in poetic manner.
Right?
It's been almost a week and I'm arguing with him only about this topic.
My question is,
is flat earth or the new gay,
should I close this topic and accept his new enlightened perspectives or should
I be worried about continuing to throw scientific facts at them?
Is that what you do with gay people?
Look you,
you both have vaginas.
Okay,
then you can't penetrate one another.
How much more scientific fact do you need that the two of you lesbian should
have a threesome with me anyways.
I don't want to escalate this thing to the breaking point,
but it feels like they're in some cult and since they are my friends,
I care.
I listen regularly.
Two to your Po podcast.
Always from Casco Stan.
Oh,
all right.
All right.
So I'll forgive the fragments here.
And this is my first time riding.
Sorry for my English.
Your answer's great.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um,
I don't know how things work in Casco Stan,
but over here in the good old United States of America,
a,
your friendship with them is hit a serious snag in the road.
So,
okay.
I mean,
you can continue to be friends with somebody that thinks the world is flat.
Just don't bring it up.
Okay.
It's like religion,
you know,
there's a bunch,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm not into it,
but I,
I,
I don't know if people,
I mean,
I hung out with people.
Scientologists seemed to be like the only people around my age that still
fucking practice their religion.
I don't,
they don't fucking bug me.
I just don't bring up religion.
I'm not gonna fucking bombard them with my stupid opinions,
my unresearched opinions.
Who gives a fuck?
You know what the funny thing is is the only reason why you and I know that the
earth is fucking round is because of other human beings that had the balls to
fucking get in a God damn boat and start sailing off into it.
So I can only make fun of these people so much.
Okay.
You're talking about somebody who took his daughter a two year old to a fucking
Tim Burton movie.
So I mean,
how much,
how far away am I from someone who thinks the fucking world is flat?
Um,
but having said that,
mmm.
I feel like you're eventually going to slowly back away from these two people if
they continue down that road.
MMM.
Yeah,
I was getting nervous that,
you know,
people were going to make fun of them to the point that they become angry people
and then all of a sudden you're the person that they take their anger out on.
These are just concerns that I have.
Uh,
all right.
Boyfriend wants to become a comedian,
by the way.
Thanks for listening to the podcast.
Way over there.
Don't you guys have a race over there?
One of the f one races over there and one of those key countries,
uh,
boyfriend wants to become a comedian.
Hey,
Billy Bald Eagle,
my boyfriend of almost two years told me when we started dating then he's been
torn between being a comedian or being a doctor.
Um,
yes,
I knew a guy that,
uh,
actually quit being a comedian to go back to med school.
Uh,
he's ridiculous,
ridiculously smart and I know he can do anything he puts his mind to.
Okay,
so are York here.
But I personally feel like he'd make a bigger difference the world being a
doctor.
And,
um,
anything could be easier to transition from being a doctor to a comedian than
the other way around.
MMM.
Well,
first of all,
it's not your life and it's not your dream.
And I can tell you that,
uh,
this is a young man and woman's business.
So all those years of studying to be a doctor and then become a comedian,
that's,
it said that could be a difficult thing.
Um,
I love him and I've told him that I'll support him no matter what he chooses,
but I purse that.
I personally think Dr is the way to go.
Is it the underlining thing that you don't think he's funny because then I get
this anyways.
Yes.
I realized that it sounds like a fucking gold digger,
but that's not why I want him to go for it.
I couldn't give a fuck about what he brings home.
That's bullshit.
That's complete bullshit.
Why?
Why,
why wouldn't you give a fuck?
That's the first thing women ask.
What do you do?
That's the guy's job.
The guy's job is to provide the woman's job is to stay home in the kitchen,
making babies.
Um,
but that seriously,
I mean that,
that is the thing.
As much as women want to put on pants and go out down the street wearing a
fucking hard hat,
you know,
you're always going to be working with guys because I mean,
what,
we can't make a baby,
you know,
we can,
we can start the fucking process,
but we're in the pit crew.
You're driving around the fucking track.
You're the ones going to have the fucking kid.
So,
uh,
you know,
all right,
my fucking record of fucking crap down for some reason it's still in the left
fucking channel.
Why is it doing this shit?
Why does it do this now?
What about this?
Does this make it better?
Does this,
is this both sides now what is it now?
It isn't.
You know what?
I'm going to have to buy a new recorder cause I don't know how to make I make
this fucking thing mark.
I was saying,
yeah,
there's nothing wrong ladies with,
with asking what a guy does for a living.
That's what you should be asking.
Cause you,
you want to,
you want to get what?
A smart guy.
Okay.
Where it becomes gold digging is if you,
you've just tell a guy that you love him when you don't because of what he's
making and then you marry them and then eventually you can't live the line he
morning and take him for everything.
He's gotten his fucking house.
Okay.
But if you're just trying to,
cause you don't want to marry a fucking dope Metzger for the human race.
If you're smart enough,
you're smart enough
to not marry a dope,
then you're going to make smart people who hopefully do good things.
So by all means,
ladies keep asking,
what do you do for a living?
You know,
there's questions that need to be asked.
that's basically the female look at females should ask that the same way guys
should be like,
are those things real?
Okay?
We're both doing our research.
Um,
anyways,
um,
I think that that guy,
uh,
like I said,
you know,
is,
is he,
I think he wants to be a comedian and his parents don't support them.
So that's always great for the comedy and a,
he sounds like a really smart guy.
If he's smart enough to be torn between the two of them,
I've made that both great jobs,
you know,
and they both really help people.
Um,
all right.
What can I end with?
Let me end with this on this one fucking speaker.
Why is it doing this?
I have everything set the way I normally said this got gotta be something on the
mixer.
I'm never going to figure this out.
Stereo.
It's this thing,
is this what I needed to do?
Did that fix any,
some just happened.
Hello?
Hello.
I liked the way that sounds.
This does this work.
And then this,
and then this.
I'm just a,
this is how I play video games.
I just start pushing the buttons.
Nothing happens.
It's,
I do stand up too.
I just push buttons.
A congratulations to Ronnie Chang.
A comic guy saw a long time ago on a fucking plane.
And I was like,
this guy's funny as hell.
And then he opened for me and Australia and then he got on the daily show and
now he just booked an acting role in this sitcom.
Um,
as did I guess to now an African American woman also boasts a congratulations,
both of them,
but unfortunately the stars are white.
So now people are saying,
I'm not going to watch the,
you know,
15 people on the Internet are saying they're not going to fucking watch it.
It's just,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm too white to understand all of that.
It's just like,
all right,
so you're not going to watch a show because of somebody's skin.
It's just a trope were thick of this.
All right.
Okay.
So if I do that,
I'm racist.
But if you do it because if you add oppression to it and the fact that white
people created this situation,
you're,
I'm not gonna use,
I hate that expression woke.
It's just been overused.
So I dunno.
I Dunno what the fucking math is on it.
I just hope People Watch it cause I love Ronny.
Chieng alright there can everybody just fucking relax.
The world is going do a head to hell and I fucking hand basket the first mammal
is extinct from fucking global warming.
Sorry.
Climate Change.
Am I in trouble with transgendered people that I used the wrong fucking
terminology there and we're running around freaking out about fucking sitcoms.
Ed fucking gender neutral bathrooms are way,
way,
way more up on the list of priority then this is not going to be any shit for us
to fucking argue about.
Maybe that is the end game.
I have no idea.
Um,
I like when people go,
I don't think that there is a god.
Why could there be a god if he would just,
if you just look at the fucking world and it's just like,
well look,
you know,
they made absolute masterpiece
masterpieces of automobiles and people bought them and then they just fucking
sat in a barn.
Does that mean the people that made them all of a sudden it's not a fucking
masterpiece?
Well,
I guess that's not a good thing because the car would act like how human beings
too.
I Dunno.
Maybe God is like,
you know,
like a crazy artist.
You know what I mean?
And just like our world is just something,
he just,
you know,
those people that don't,
they don't really paint,
they just throw fucking paint at a canvas and they get naked and they roll
around on it.
They have to put Turpentine and their pubes afterwards and somehow after they
die,
it's like worth like fucking 10 million bucks.
Maybe that's what he did.
I have no idea.
Um,
but anyway,
I'm going to watch it because Ronnie Chang's in it and as a white person I love,
I love a white lead.
I'm not racist.
I'm just a proud white podcast.
I'm fucking around.
I don't,
I don't watch sitcoms.
I watch,
I watch sports and I'm going to go watch the Moto GP,
but,
um,
I guess that's it,
right?
I'm going to do with the garden of dreams on April 2nd.
I'll check in on you on Thursday and hopefully a,
I can have somebody fix this fucking recorder.
I don't know what the problem is.
You know what the problem is?
It's me,
so I apologize.
All right,
I'll see ya.